[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, guys.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
And I've been working on the
Web Lab project with these
guys here, Roger and Mattias.
That's right?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes!
I've got it right again.
So guys, do you want to give
yourself a little bit of
introduction about who
you are, what you do,
where you're from.
ROGER PALA: I'm Roger.
I'm from Barcelona.
I'm a creative technologist
at B-Reel.
And I've been the technical
leader of this project.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL:
And I'm Mattias.
I'm a creative technologist
as well.
I'm from some Uppsala, a
small city in Sweden.
And I've been working mainly
on the Orchestra.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So, yes.
Today's talk. at least, Is about
the Universal Orchestra
Experiment.
For those who don't know about
Web Lab, I'll just give you a
little bit of a background
to it.
Web Lab is a series of five
real-world Chrome experiments
based inside the British Science
Museum here in London,
but with a real, solid
internet presence.
So every experiment that you
can interact with at the
museum, you can also interact
with at home online and work
through your browser.
Now, the really interesting
thing as well, for me at
least, are the experiences that
you have on your desktop
machine are really quite similar
to the experiences
that you have inside
the museum itself.
So that's pretty cool.
The second most important thing
is that everything you
do inside the museum is recorded
against your own
unique lab tag, which if you
watch the Lab Tag Explorer
Hangout that we did earlier
on, you will see that
basically you can go home, put
your camera or put the lab tag
up in front of your camera,
and then get access to
everything that you just created
in the museum as well
as online, as well.
So it's a pretty cool
experience, right?
And today is the piece
de resistance.
I don't know whether that's
right or what I'm saying.
It's one of the best things
about the museum, is the
Universal Orchestra Experiment,
which, if we've
done this right, you'll hear
in the background.
[TONES PLAY]
PAUL KINLAN: Playing.
So the Universal Orchestra,
I think it's about eight
instruments.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
Eight instruments.
PAUL KINLAN: Eight physical,
real instruments.
As you can see in the background
right now, we've
got drums, marimbas.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Kalimba.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, kalim--
there's like all these
instruments I'd never
heard of, right?
Ever.
They're awesome,
though, right?
And you can interact
with them either at
the museum or online.
And you can make a band.
The two join together.
For me, this is the experiment
where both sides kind of come
together into one
big experience.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
And the thought behind this
is to show real-time
collaboration and that
the internet is
facilitating that for you.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
So shall we dive in?
ROGER PALA: Yep.
Let's have a look.
PAUL KINLAN: As with every
Hangout, I normally mention
how this was made.
I only learned this myself just
recently, and I'm not
going to tell you.
No, it was--
was it Swiffy?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: It was a Flash
file, Swiffy-ized, which is a
Google Tool on
chrome.google.com, passed
through that and made in
HTML and JavaScript.
So this is actually really
interesting right now, is we
have two different modes.
We have the real-time mode,
and we're going
to go through both.
So this a longer-than-normal
Hangout, essentially.
But we're going to
go through both.
One is the online version, which
I say online, the one
that interacts with the
real instruments.
But sometimes those instruments
might be fully
booked up with people playing
online at the time or inside
the museum.
And you can get a pure online
virtual experience as well.
We'll dive into the real museum,
the real experience,
the museum experience first.
Now, the really cool thing about
this to me is this is a
live stream of the
museum, isn't it?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It's only
like a couple of
seconds delayed, is it?
A few seconds of delay?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah, I think
around here, it might be
4 or 5 seconds, and then
when you get in
live, it's 3 seconds.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's
pretty cool, this.
Well, it's buffering
right now, but I'll
blame YouTube for that.
So we'll jump into
it at least.
So we'll jump in.
Again, this is the live view
of the experiment.
We have our different
instruments.
There is one person playing
at the moment.
Which is a good instrument?
Should we jump in and play an
instrument straight away?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Let's go
for the steel drums.
PAUL KINLAN: Steel drums?
There we are.
So we'll join in the queue.
So this is the steel
drum playing at the
museum right now.
There is no one in the queue for
this one, so we should be
able to jump on pretty quick.
I imagined if we joined
at a busy time, we'd
have a bit of a wait.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
And during the opening time of
the museum, four instruments
are reserved for museum users.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I mean, that was actually-- when
I took the kids to the
museum, that was a good thing,
is that we could
actually get on.
I was worried about people
coming online and stealing an
instrument from me.
But it wasn't like that.
I got to play it myself.
So let's join the queue.
And then it should-- it says
less than a minute, so we'll
have a chat for a minute.
Hey, we're done.
So we're in.
We have a minute to respond.
I'm ready.
Let's jump in.
I love how this whole experiment
is like all the
experiments-- seamless
navigation between the views.
It's pretty cool.
So we've actually got six
different notes that we can
play on this grid.
If you're familiar with the
MIDI synthesizers and
sequencers and all that
type of stuff, it's a
similar type of thing.
Should we put some on?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, should we
have a listen to what's
playing in the background
first?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: Sounds cool.
So what you'll find is as while
we're actually doing
this, we can't actually hear
what's happening, because
otherwise, the microphone
audio will be
a little bit crazy.
But we have two instruments
left that we can position.
Can you explain to me a little
bit about what's going on, why
the button kind of glowed and
slowly went out, and wasn't
there straight away?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yes.
So normally, when it comes to
real-time collaboration,
people don't see the latency,
which here is 3 seconds, and
we wanted to show it.
So it's actually, you have done
something, but it hasn't
happened yet.
So that's what we're showing
off, and that's why the
physics of the globes
are as they are.
So if you drag one, it will
stop, and you release it, and
you know it's going
to get there.
But it hasn't yet got there,
so now it has.
PAUL KINLAN: I like that.
Thank you.
So it's kind of interesting,
because what we're trying to
show is that actually, there's
up to eight different
participants, and they're all--
they all need to be
synchronized to hear the same
piece of music roughly about
the same time.
Otherwise, it would just be a
terrible music experience, if
it wasn't playing it out.
So the other video before
was YouTube live.
Is this a YouTube live
video, or is this--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: No.
This is one with lower latency,
so we're going
directly to the source and
getting the video from there.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, pretty cool.
So I pretty much see what's
happening with a minimal delay
between the two.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
And we wanted to make sure that
the audio was in sync
with the initials as well, so
that's where the 3-second
buffering time comes from.
PAUL KINLAN: I realized that.
It feels nice, right?
Well, it feels slower.
Not slow.
It feels gluey.
It's like, oh, you
get it across.
But it feels kind of nice, the
way that you're showing that
there is latency.
Normally what happens on
the web, it's terrible.
They use a white screen, or
you'll see things kind of load
in and all that type of stuff.
It feels kind of nice, the
way that this is--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Or it could
be faked as well, kind of
showing a delay when
you actually know
what's going to happen.
But this is what's going on.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
This is pretty cool.
So I mean, this is going
to sound silly, right?
What is the--
is this Canvas?
Just a Canvas thing?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
It's a 2-D Canvas drawing
everything on every frame.
PAUL KINLAN: How are the clients
all synchronized?
I mean, it's pretty hard to
synchronize two people
together just normally.
I mean, you've got eight people
synchronized now with
this with a user interface.
Can you explain a little
bit how the actual
synchronization works?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yes.
So everyone gets the time from
the timestamp in the video.
So it doesn't matter what your
clocks say on the system.
It's what the video says the
time is that dictates how it's
going to be shown.
And then we're using WebSockets
to broadcast all
the messages to everyone.
So here in a matter of
milliseconds, they can see
what's happening.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, So
something happens,
basically, on the client.
You'll send it to the server
via WebSocket as well.
And then do you have to wait for
it to be synchronized on
the service before you
then send that back
out to all the clients?
Is that what you're saying?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
So we have the real-time server
that takes care of all
that synchronization, sends it
to the museum, and gets a
reply back, I'm going to play
this note at this time, sends
it out to everyone else.
But before it got the reply
from the museum, it has
already broadcasted out this
is going to happen.
We just--
PAUL KINLAN: I got you.
It sends a confirmation.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
You just don't know the time
when it's going to happen, but
it's coming.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So I mean, App Engine doesn't
support WebSockets, right?
And you're using WebSockets.
So how did you actually
build that part out?
Was it like a NoJS server
or something?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yes,
so we have--
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, sweet.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: A NoJS
server, so all
the JavaScript running.
PAUL KINLAN: Is it
a lot of code?
I imagine it's not.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It's
not that much.
And we implemented the
WebSockets from scratch, just
reading the specification
and sending as
small messages as possible.
And they are around 4 or
5 bytes, every message
that are sent out.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty
small, isn't it?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And we use App
Engine for the queueing.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, actually,
we didn't talk about that.
So how does the queueing work?
Because I can imagine that
there's only four instruments
that you can play any
one particular time.
If you have a lot of people
visiting the museum, obviously
they can queue up in
a physical line.
I mean, if you're online,
how does that work?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: So what we saw
earlier was the little bar
at the top saying how far you
are into the queue and how
long you have to wait.
And so people are just queueing
up, and if you're
queueing, you can say the
virtual experience to interact
with other while
you're waiting.
PAUL KINLAN: So what type of
technology do you use in the
back end to actually
manage the queue?
Is it just you pull
every so often?
Or is it tasked?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah, it's
pulling, which App Engine's
good at doing.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's pretty good at scaling
that stuff up.
That's pretty interesting.
So it is literally a first-in,
first-out queue?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: You just basically
manage and kind of
pop it off.
That's pretty cool.
That was actually quicker than
I thought it would be.
Shall we have a look at the
live online experience?
This is actually pretty
cool as well.
So the thing I like about the
museum one is you literally
are playing the instruments with
people in the museum, and
you get the live stream back,
and it's pretty nice.
What should we say about the
Play Online version?
Why was this created?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Just for
more people to play.
We were thinking, if it's a long
queue, then people will
still want to do something,
and having a virtual one
enables us to have hundreds of
users at the same time instead
of just eight.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
So let's load the sequencer
and see how it goes.
Fundamentally, this seems like
a relatively similar concept
between the real physical
machine, the installation
version, and the actual
online version.
I mean, is it literally
the same code?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah, for
the display and for the
interaction between it.
But then here we using audio API
to play the samples, which
are taken from the instruments
in the museum.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool, So
how would you play--
I mean, I'm just going
to put some stuff.
Well, there's actually quite
a few people playing now.
So let's play the--
the--
thing.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know
what it's called.
That's pretty cool.
I like that.
It's nice.
So yeah, I mean--
what was the question?
Yeah, so how do you
actually play?
I mean, you said you were
playing the audio back, and
you presampled the sounds.
The audio tag in most browsers
is known to be very sensitive
to latency.
I say sensitive.
It's very latent, has
high latency.
I mean, how did you
get around this?
Because it seems like it's
pretty responsive.
As soon as it says it's going
to play, it plays it.
How did you do that?
Did you use the audio tag?
Web Audio?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: We're using
Web Audio for this one, which
is perfect for this kind, and
you can just tell it when to
start playing a sound, and it
plays exactly at that point.
So we have a background loop of
four bars, and then we add
on on top of that.
And everything stays
synchronized, which would be
impossible with the audio tag.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
I imagine as well you don't
think we need an amazing
amount of --
like every client to be
amazingly in sequence with
each of these now, because it's
not playing the physical
instrument and streaming
it back out.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: So they're
actually playing.
You don't know if they are at
the same bar as you, but they
get your changes.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: This
is pretty cool.
I really like the effect that
when two people are sharing
the same note, essentially, at
the same time, it's get a nice
little animation.
I presume that's just
a normal Canvas
animation between the two.
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So I mean, you have
this button here
that says Record Session.
How does that work?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: So that one,
we are just recording all the
changes and what's been playing,
and when we play it
back, we start the same thing.
We start a player in this
interface to show it off.
So it doesn't generate
an audio file.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so it's
not generating--
yeah, that's pretty cool.
So it's not generating a
physical audio file.
It generates like a MIDI file,
essentially, where the notes
are playing at a particular
time and then you just
rerecord that.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So if I press
Stop, does it cancel it?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It
will cancel it.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, I'll
leave that.
I'll let it go for another
4 seconds then.
This is pretty cool.
So let's see if this works.
Oh, that's nice.
Yep.
Save to Lab.
It's doing its magic.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Here you go.
PAUL KINLAN: So we can
play it from there.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: You can see
all the changes happening.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, that's
really cool.
Oh, that's when I moved
it down as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: That's
really nice.
And that, again, is just the
Canvas animation with Web
Audio playing.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So I mean, a lot of
people kind of are worried
about starting to play with
Web Audio, and you know,
obviously, it's a
Chrome thing.
Well, it's Chrome and Safari
now, at least, anyway.
I mean, did you have any issues
with Web Audio itself?
It was relatively immature, I
think, when you guys started
the project.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah, it's
was simply straightforward
from the beginning.
It's quite an easy thing
to get into.
You have samples that you want
to play, and you can add
effects, and you don't have
to code that much.
You can just take
the good things
and connect it together.
ROGER PALA: Less trouble than
the audio tag code.
PAUL KINLAN: Really?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
ROGER PALA: Although it
seems easier to use.
It's not, at the
end of the day.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
Yeah, I think that's the first
thing that people naturally
gravitate towards, is the audio
tag, because you have a
dot play and dot pause,
essentially, which I always
thought should've been stopped,
but regardless.
ROGER PALA: Even in looping, for
example, on the audio tags
is quite tricky.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Right.
I really liked this.
I didn't actually realize that
you didn't physically record
the output.
So you just record the
events, essentially.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
That's pretty cool.
My big thing about
this, I like the
collaborative aspect of it.
It's the one thing that
I find that is most
powerful about the web.
When you're trying to compare
native applications and web
applications is we tend on the
web to have always been
building collaborative-based
experiences.
We've found it a lot easier to
do that on native platforms.
I think this one really
kind of shows off a
lot really cool stuff.
And the fact is, I mean, when
we actually demoed this
before, we were practicing what
happened, and no one was
playing at the time.
We were kind of worried.
So we've got quite a few
people now playing from
Brazil, United States.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And it's quite
interesting to see where
people are playing from.
Someone in Mexico sitting
there playing
the exact same time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I wonder if they think
that I'm a
cool musician or something.
He's really good, this guy.
That's nice.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And what you
can say about the virtual as
well, you see the latency
of WebSockets there.
Because in the one in the
museum, it's the delay of the
video to get that synced.
But for the virtual,
we don't have that.
So you see that when you drag
it, it kind of releases
directly, and it's been
traveling all the way to--
I think Las Vegas is where
our server is.
PAUL KINLAN: Wow.
That's pretty cool.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty exciting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: I kind of--
yeah, I'm just amazed
at the level of
awesomeness that this--
I like all the projects.
I think this is my favorite
of the five experiments
altogether.
I like the fact that you can
just stream it through and see
what's happening
in the museum.
I remember the other day, I saw
someone actually fixing
the machine.
I was planning all the Hangouts
and everything, and I
was like, oh, there's someone
fixing the machine.
And they were just moving stuff
around a little bit, and
the whole thing was
just a nice--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And you can
see people dance around the
instruments.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
The other thing is I like the
confluence of YouTube Live to
actually kind of handle
the scale of it.
Because I can imagine that
there's lots and lots of
people always on this page.
And then when you get to your
own instrument, well, you know
that you can deliver a direct
channel to the person then.
You don't need to scale
that out so much.
You need to make sure
it works, right?
But you don't need to check
too much on there.
It's pretty cool.
I like that.
It's good.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Congratulations.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Thanks.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I think that is the end of
this Hangout, at least.
If you'd like to learn more,
we're going to have some
articles on HTML5 Rocks.
These guys are going
to produce an
article on HTML5 Rocks.
If not--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: See, this is--
so we're going to hopefully
try and do a bit more of a
technical deep dive.
This is obviously--
this sits in the middle of the
documentation on the site,
which is into how it works
and the kind of very more
technical information.
We're tried to give you like a
nice little middle ground of
showing you how the technologies
are used together
and how the guys built it.
So thank you very much, and
we'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]